belleville 10e arrondissement de paris
un quartier où mes compatriotes sont de
plus en plus nombreux
je suis journaliste chinoise et je vis à
paris depuis deux ans
tout ici me rappelle mon pays tous sauf
ces groupes de chinoise tant
l'impression de se promener sans but
précis elles ont la cinquantaine
s'habille sans artifice pourtant leur
comportement est sans équivoque
lorsqu'elle croise le regard d'un homme
c'est celui de paix à la recherche d'un
client je suis intrigué en chine cette
forme de prostitution n'existe pas
muni d'une caméra cachée je décide
d'enquêter sur 7
notre type je me présente à elle comme
une jeune étudiante fraîchement arrivé
de pékin est à la recherche de travail
bien rémunéré
tu as quel âge
je suis âgée j'ai plus de 40 ans tu as
l'air jeune ici comment on peut faire
pour gagner de l'argent
faut oser faire des choses quel genre de
choses des choses qui te permettent de
gagner vite de l'argent et comment tu
fais pour gagner vite de l'argent
mais il ya plein de petits boulots qui
rapportent mais le plus simple c'est
encore de vente et services tu veux dire
quoi
oui là au moins c'est immédiat mais il
faut avoir le courage de le faire
moi j'ai une question tu lis ici pour
étudier ou bien pour travailler dis-le
moi
les deux je n'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
et je ne veux pas que mes parents mon
envoi pour payer mes études mais tu sais
il vaudrait mieux que tu trouves un
travail normal je te conseille de ne pas
tuer beaucoup trop jeune pour ça
[Musique]
d'autres se sont jointes à la discussion
elles ont moins de scrupules et n'hésite
pas à encourager dans cette voie
et tout le monde écoute et elle a dit
qu'elle n'a plus d'argent et l envie de
trouver un boulot ou on gagne facilement
de l'argent
je lui ai conseillé de vendre sa part
ouais
et n'oublie pas de m
bon merci pour les conseils s'il te fait
un bébé tout est fichu il faut qu'ils te
paye d'abord et m
et surtout quand tu travailles il ne
faut pas que les enlève certains ont des
maladies contagieuses doit leur demander
beaucoup au moins 30 ou 40 euros si je
peux demander plus 50 60 70 euros toi tu
es jeune et jolie il te donneront plus
oui mais il faut que tu te demandes
toujours l'argent avant là s'il ne te
donne pas d'argent tu ne fais rien avec
eux
et toi tu leur demande combien
le minimum c'est un euro parfois tu peux
demander 40 euros moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui une à 40 euros mais la
plupart il refuse de donner plus
20 40 euros la passe ces deux à cinq
fois moins cher que la plupart des qui
font le trottoir à paris en moins de
cinq minutes j'en ai rencontré une
dizaine je découvre vite qu'elles ont
même un nom dans le quartier les
marcheuses parce qu'elle arpente sans
cesse les mêmes rues
apparemment elles sont beaucoup plus
nombreuses que je ne l'imaginais
[Musique]
suffisamment pour que les services de
police les désigne comme l'une de leurs
cibles prioritaires
[Musique]
si la police s'intéresse tellement elle
sait que les marcheuses ont étendu leur
territoire à d'autres quartiers de la
capitale ouais donc sur les deux
marcheurs qui sont boulevard de la
guyane il y en a une plus grande c'est
le cas de la porte dorée à l'est de
paris c'est là que je retrouve les
policiers du sc cité le service de
soutien aux investigations territoriales
qui sont en planque pour interpeller des
marcheuses pour racolage ouais on
s'accorde un petit peu de temps pour
faire une bonne physionomie du secteur
donc il ya la marcheuse avec sa veste
marron qui remontaient sur saint mandé
on a les deux demoiselles qui sont sur
le banc boulevard de la guyane en
attente et on a les deux filles qui sont
sous le pont à droite vers les jardins
quand on passe sous perry fins et reçus
yann et le chef d'unité il connaît bien
ces femmes et leurs habitudes pour pour
me mettre en attente son trottoir en
face il est 18h l'heure de sortie des
bureaux en moins d'une heure lui et ses
hommes repèrent un flagrant délit deux
[Musique]
oui à temps ouais alors au de yann
regarde la demoiselle envers elle va
partir avec un client l'a donc tu la
vois pas il va monter dans une ford
immatriculée
[Musique]
ouais je te confie en 1ère regarde
autour d'elle et elle monte à bord le
véhicule est immatriculé
alors attend en fait je pense qu'il va
pas monter avec lui et lui a indiqué un
endroit et elle part à pied tout seul
donc l'aller devant moi et sur le
terre-plein central ah d'accord ok je
passerai vu dans quel monde dans la
voiture laurent fait elle monte dans la
voiture a elle va ils vont arriver au
feu à l'angle du lycée des marcs et
chaussées reçu
ouais c'est une ford orion 1 après dix
minutes de filature en voiture le client
et la prostitue chinoise pénètre dans le
parking d'un centre commercial
descendez s'il vous plaît
c'est pas une
c'est bon
des cochons
dans la voiture s'il vous plaît on vous
reproche infractions de racolage public
élite racolage public le fait de se
et de racoler des clients sur la voie
publique
elle comprend patiemment le français
pourrait comprendre très très peu mais
là pas envie de comprendre qu'il est
placé en garde à vue et qu'elle a donc
l'interprète avait notifié dès qu'on
sera de retour au bureau alors justement
le client qu'est ce qu'ils risquent
rien puisqu'en fait
il est entendu à titre de simple
témoignage est donc maintenant qu'on a
recueilli son témoignage c'est qu'il a
confirmé auprès de laurent les éléments
qu'on nous n'avons observé précédemment
donc ça caractérise pour nous le
racolage public et donc on met à
demoiselles en garde à vue
non
retour au commissariat pour rien et son
équipe
risque de mois de prison pour racolage
sur la voie publique mais elle est aussi
expulsables immédiatement si elle n'a
pas de titre de séjour
c'est en situation régulière
sans titre séjour est valable jusqu'au 6
cinq de nos six
une chinoise rentrée avec un visa
touriste en france comme la plupart des
marcheuses et les similitudes ne
s'arrêtent pas là
elles ont sensiblement tous à peu près
le même âge on va dire une fourchette
entre 35 et 50 ans et elles viennent
tous de même de la même région
pratiquement et on bouge plus cette
région située au nord-est de pékin c'est
l'ancien mandchourie appelé aujourd'hui
le dongbei
en moins d'un an c'est sa cinquième
arrestation et jusqu'à présent elle s'en
est toujours sorti avec une
contravention et une nuit de garde à vue
elle est où l'adresse de son logeur à
paris ménilmontant et plus précisément
aux minimes ont tancé vague mais ni
moussa à ménilmontant je sais pas vous
êtes combien dans ce logement
a fléchi
yogo jeunes défendent bien yougov indien
ils sont six ans un studio et vous êtes
venus de pékin
little king live direct paris ce qui est
en votre avis d'accord avec un passeport
mais il va être favre d'autoroute or il
est où le passeport
les ghettos rios un jeu trop tôt c'est
le passeur qui la reprise une fois mon
arrivée en france et vous avez payé
combien le passeur wildlife aguanish on
le dit moins
80 millions
80 jeunes ça fait numéro millions euros
oui mais l'euro et l'argent vous l'aviez
les les 8000 euros vous avez eu 8000
euros
touche au pied non j'ai
emprunté la totalité de la somme 8000
euros pour rentrer clandestinement en
france une somme qui équivaut à plus de
dix ans de salaire d'un ouvrier en chine
c'est la majorité des filles chinoises
je dirais 99% des défis chinois sont
viennent de chine pour travailler soit
dans la confection comme aux gardes
d'enfants dans le milieu chinois et
comme il ya pas placer 20 faut
rembourser la dette donc elle alla 8000
euros à rembourser donc elle en vient à
se
me tiens plus tôt
tavant en chine mais je te demande si tu
te prostituer avant en chine où jamais
j'aurais pensé que je pourrais me
prostituer un jour mais qu'est ce que tu
veux que je fasse mais si je trouve pas
de boulot
nous sommes bien que ses fils à se sont
pas des délinquantes au sens commun du
terme qu'on peut concevoir en france
mais d'un autre côté on peut pas non
plus laisser faire on comprend sa
détresse mais c'est qu'on peut pas non
plus laisser faire parce que si on
laisse faire elle en valant à ses fans
c'est un phénomène qui devient
exponentielle des dizaines des centaines
combien sont-elles impossible de le
savoir
discrète
insaisissable la plupart n'ont pas de
souteneur en fait les marcheuses ne
répondent en rien aux critères d autres
exercices à paris
je décide d'aller en chine dans la
région de dumbéa shenyang la capitale de
l'ancienne mandchourie je veux savoir
comment et pourquoi autant de femmes qui
tout pour finir sur les trottoirs
parisiens
pas besoin de se promener longtemps pour
comprendre dans les années 80 1400
entreprises d'état fournissez le pays
tout entier
aujourd'hui près des deux tiers ont fait
faillite c'est l'autre visage de la
libéralisation du marché chinois
notre régime faisait partie des trois
plus importantes entreprises de vélo
nous ont fabriqué les vélos de la marque
bichonne
la société a fait faillite en 1997
lusine de vélo compter presque 5000
personnes il y en a deux mille quatre
cent qui sont à la retraite et les
autres ont été licenciés
reste une petite centaine de salariés
qui hante le site payé à ne rien faire
chaque jour ils se retrouvent entre
ancien et ressassent leur souvenir en
regardant les photos de la grande époque
regarde cette photo là c'est moi avec le
secrétaire du parti de l'époque louis
vous connaissez des gens qui sont partis
à l'étranger à l'étranger pas moi en
tout cas il faut être riche pour partir
si tu n'as pas d'argent comment tu peux
offrir ce luxe si t'as pas 80 millions à
tout quitte pas le pays
8000 euros pour quitter le pays
visiblement tout le monde est au courant
des tarifs pratiqués à shenyang même mon
taxi
mille euros c'est ce qu'il faut payer
pour un visa touriste à shenyang ce sont
les agences de voyages qui s'en occupe
il y en a beaucoup qui servent
d'intermédiaires pour les candidats au
départ
mon chauffeur de taxi connais une femme
qui à utiliser ce système pour partir en
france son père a accepté de me recevoir
il a était contremaître dans les travaux
publics pendant plus de trente ans il a
deux enfants un fils de 25 ans cheveux
et une fille de 40 l'oeil ils ont tous
les deux quitté shenyang pour l'étranger
pratiquement en même temps regarde
surtout de ces photos c'est ma fille
c'était il ya bientôt cinq ans
là c'est en france j'ai encore plein de
photos d'elle tendu
géographe coup on est elle est déjà
rentrée non en cinq ans n'ont pas une
seule fois pourquoi parce qu'elle n'a
pas de papiers en france mais elle
espère bientôt en avoir pour demander la
nationalité française il faut avoir vécu
5 ans là bas ou alors il faut se marier
et elle s'est mariée avec un français
non elle cherche bien sûr elle en a
envie mais ne trouve pas elle était
mariée en chine oui elle était mariée on
a même eu un enfant
ils sont séparés
oui ça fait longtemps terme et ne
viennent tout juste de divorcer
pourquoi ils se sont séparés
pourquoi comment dire ne s'entendait
plus
il n'avait plus de travail tous les deux
ils n'arrivaient plus à joindre les deux
bouts
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de trouver
un travail dans la région
même pour les gens qui ont des diplômes
c'est compliqué de trouver un emploi
alors pour des gens comme nous qui
n'avons rien c'est pire et maintenant
elle gym et en france
en france elle fait partie des plus
pauvres
tout ce qu'elle gagne elle le dépenses
pour la nourriture et le logement
depuis cinq ans elle n'arrive pas à
mettre de l'argent de côté elle n'a rien
économiser nom vient du tout
je vais essayer de retrouver l'oeil à
paris mais son père n'a qu'un numéro de
téléphone portable
regarde ça c'est en italie je crois que
hig rallye visiblement une idée très
vague de l'endroit où elle habite
je réalise combien à 8000 km de distance
il est facile de tout faire croire à sa
famille
[Musique]
mais avant de quitter génial je veux en
savoir plus sur ce visa à 8000 euros
direction le quartier des agences de
voyages
ici je vais en trouver des dizaines aux
étages de ces immeubles
de simples bureaux qui ressemble à tout
sauf aux agences de voyages
traditionnelles
[Musique]
comment faire concrètement pour avoir un
visa
les démarches sont assez compliqué il
faut avoir un minimum de 3000 euros sur
son compte pour avoir un visa c'est une
caution bancaire on appelle ça une
garantie de retour au pays j'ai entendu
dire que ça coûte parfois jusqu'à 8000
euros c'est vrai ça dépend de la
destination un visa touriste pour la
corée du sud ses 10000 euros le japon
c'est parra et 10000 pour l'europe ça
varie entre 5 et 10 mille euros et ça
consiste en quoi
on ne sait jamais si un client va rester
ou va revenir en chine cette caution
c'est une assurance pour nous parce que
si l'un d'entre eux restent dans le pays
nous on doit payer une amende au
consulat sinon il ne nous donne plus de
visas
pour les consulats étrangers un système
de caution tout à fait officielle qui
leur permet de repérer les filières
clandestines d'immigration déguisé en
agences de voyages
8000 euros rappelez vous c'est aussi le
prix pratiqués par les passeurs de la
marcheuse prise en flagrant délit de
racolage à paris
je suis de retour à belleville
je n'ai pas réussi à retrouver l'oeil
son portable ne répond pas et je ne
trouve pas le café où elle était censée
travailler
ce soir j rendez vous chez un marchand
de sommeil connu dans le quartier pour
loger des marcheuses je veux louer une
de ses chambres pour savoir comment
vivent ces femmes toujours en caméra
cachée je vais me faire passer pour une
fille du dongbei tout juste débarqué à
paris
en fait deux chambres je réalise très
vite qu'au mieux j'aurais peut-être
droit un lit et pour ne rien arranger le
propriétaire est méfiant
les lions l'air plein là
pourquoi ça t'intéresse bah oui j'ai une
amie qui est intéressé aussi
vous voulez dormir ensemble ou vous
voulez chacune à me séparer
il faut voir ça dépend des conditions
les conditions dures bien qu'elles sont
mauvaises les conditions il ya beaucoup
de monde ici n'était pas déjà venu toi
non c'est la première fois vous avez
plus d espace ailleurs ou pas
non pour l'instant c'est tout ce qu'on a
il ya des gens qui vont partir ayant lui
l'un va falloir qu'il dégage rapidement
c'est un mauvais payeur il a aucune
parole
[Musique]
je suis effaré par ce que je vois
l'appartement ne fait pas plus de 20
mètres carrés et je compte environ 15
lits superposés
certains sont occupés par des couples
qui dorment tête bêche en guise de
cloisons entre les couchages le
propriétaire a tendu une simple
couverture
ça coûte combien par mois
ces 120 euros c'est pareil pour tout le
monde ah oui mais on me dit que ça
coûtait 100 euros non non non c'est 120
euros il y en a seulement 1 c'est au
troisième étage là je veux jeter un coup
d'oeil vas-y regarde c'est celui là oui
à quelqu'un maintenant mais s'en va
demain
malgré des prix exorbitants le ballet
des locataires clandestins est ainsi ça
et
il faut rester au minimum combien de
temps
non il n'ya pas du minimum tu veut
habiter à moins tu payes un mois mais tu
paye toujours d' avance
je demande à aller aux toilettes
c'est encore pire
comment 15 personnes peuvent-elles
cohabiter dans de telles conditions
l'atmosphère est irrespirable
oppressante
mais je veux savoir si des marcheuses
habite aussi si le pari vous logez
beaucoup de gens de dongbei oui bien sûr
il ya plein de filles du dongbei est
l'ailé du dongbei celles qui sont
absentes elles sont du dongbei même
celle qui fait les raviolis vapeur dans
la cuisine elle est de là-bas
tu veux manger non merci tu viens d'où
je viens de dongbei juste à côté de chez
niane toi moi je viens de shenyang dans
le liaoning
mais à trop poser de questions sur
l'origine des locataires j'ai veille les
soupçons du logeur
je suis sûr qu'elle ait même pas là pour
habiter elle vient pour vous interviewez
elle vient ici pour savoir comment on
traite les madame qui viennent chez nous
et les madame elles font quoi et c'est
quoi leur avenir ici
non je ne suis pas journaliste je suis
étudiante pourquoi je viendrai poser des
questions
alors aujourd'hui tu viens pour fouiner
où tu viens pour le oui non pour me
loger alors pourquoi tu poses toutes ces
questions j'ai peur qu'ils aient repéré
ma caméra cachée
pour plus de sécurité
je décide d'abréger la conversation et
de quitter l'appartement en prétextant
un rendez vous urgent
après deux semaines d'enquêté je n'ai
toujours pas réussi à convaincre une
marcheuse de témoigner je me tourne vers
médecins du monde marie connaît bien les
prix chinois de belleville avec son bus
cela fait bientôt deux ans qu'elle
sillonne le quartier pour les
sensibiliser au problème du sida il lui
a fallu plusieurs mois pour établir le
contact avec ces femmes c'est la raison
pour laquelle elle n'a pas voulu que
notre caméra soit présente pendant ses
consultations ces des femmes qui ont du
mal à comprendre qu'une association
humanitaire puisse être indépendante de
l'état de la police maintenant qu'on est
bien identifiées elles viennent
après c'est très variable il ya des
femmes qui qui peut-être parce qu'elle
nous connaissent bien savent qu'ils en
aient je ne sais pas parle facilement de
leurs problèmes
2 oui je me suis fait arrêter par les
policiers ça s'est passé comme ça ou pas
et d'autres au contraire où c'est très
difficile d'entrer en discussion
au delà de leurs pratiques à risque ce
qui inquiète surtout marie c'est que la
plupart des marcheuses qu'elle rencontre
ont une méconnaissance totale du milieu
c'est sûr que quand on a un certain âge
comme la plupart ces femmes
contre 2
pour la quarantaine en moyenne
on ne peut pas avoir les réflexes
d'une personne qui connaît vraiment le
monde les risques qui sont ni compris
par rapport à des violences que ce soit
des clients ou autre donc je
effectivement ces femmes là donc ne
demandent peut-être pas toutes les
précautions qu'on peut pas voir d'autres
personnes plus habitué au travail dgt
en janvier dernier une marcheuse a été
retrouvé
un détraqué
effectivement toutes les conversations
que j'ai filmé en caméra cachée me
confirme que les
chinoise de belleville respectent
rarement les règles élémentaires de
sécurité
et vous le faites à l'hôtel ou chez eux
à l'hôtel ou chez eux ça dépend une fois
que j'entre dans la chambre tu demande
s'il est tout seul il va dire oui et
puis tu regardes par toi même j'avais
fait ça moi et quand il n'y a personne
je suis contente
normalement ils sont tous seuls
ce matin là les filles m'emmène à la
supérette du coin c'est ici qu'elle
achète le seul repas qu'elle s'autorise
par jour elles sont obligés de compter
chaque euro pour vivre
[Musique]
ce sont des pattes de cochon oui avec ma
copine on adore ça tu adores ça moi je
n'aime pas
combien vous en voulez de jean veut
d'eux s'il vous plaît à vous parler
chinois combien ça coûte les pattes là
j'en veux pour un euro 25 centimes par
pat j'en veux pour un euro bah pour à
nos hôtes henri iv
1 euro 50 pour un show ils sont malades
c'est plus cher que quatre pattes de
cochon
tu vois nous on galère mais toi jolie et
jeune comme tu es tu pourrais te faire
des millions sont usés comme nous
allez on s'en va faut pas qu'on parle de
ça les gens pourraient nous entendre
une fois sorti les marcheuses on se
faire encore plus insistantes si je ne
vais pas plus loin j'ai peur que les
comprenne que je ne suis pas celle que
je prétends être je décide de les
abandonner là
deux mois ont passé ma patience a fini
par payer j'ai sympathisé avec une femme
d'une cinquantaine d'années c'est la
première à qui je vais avouer que je
suis journaliste
elle accepte de répondre à mes questions
mais elle a peur des représailles
je l'appellerai mail pour sa sécurité
cela fait un an qu'elle est arrivée en
france
et
ra ra rapide tu apprends le français
depuis combien de temps un mois et demi
c'est difficile bon c'est pas facile
baby sitting ménages massage mais y
cumule les petits boulots sans arriver à
en vivre alors régulièrement elles sont
dans le travail comment ils sont les
français est ce que ce sont de mauvais
payeurs et comment tu fais s'ils veulent
profiter de toi
je ne fais pas
ce n'est pas la peine de travailler
s'il n'a pas l'air gentil je ne fais pas
ça fait longtemps que je suis ici donc
je sais qui est bien et qui ne l'est pas
on quoi qu'il arrive ma priorité est la
sécurité
le soir même je retrouve may qui a
demandé un de ses clients réguliers si
je pouvais être là pendant sa séance de
massage un massage normale à 20 euros
pour 10 euros de plus elle va plus loin
avec ceux qui le souhaitent et ils sont
nombreux vous faites souvent des
massages un peu plus poussées comme ça
va
ça veut dire quoi ça va
combien de fois par jour ou un sur deux
en général
était client comment ils te contacte
par téléphone
et ils t'appellent souvent qu'elle
souvent
souvent des clients qui reviennent
et où est ce que tu fais ce genre de
massage a toujours à leur domicile chez
les clients oui tu n'as pas peur
prévenant je n'ai pas peur
la plupart je les connais maintenant
pour certains s'il ne se comporte pas
bien je ne le fais pas je m'en vais
s'ils sont louches je n'y vais pas
et personne ne le sait dans ta famille
nombreuse je ne peux pas le dire sinon
ils vont me mépriser et les autres
qu'est ce qu'elles disent à leurs
familles rien bien sûr personne n'ose
rien dire sinon on va être rejetée par
sa famille il faut avoir perdu tout son
amour propre pour avouer ce genre de
choses la chine est un pays conservateur
comment les parents pourraient tolérer
ça ça t'arrive de déprime est parfois
bien sûr que oui quand je fais ça je
suis très triste je ne veux pas faire ça
je pleure secrètement tous les soirs je
n'aurais jamais cru que je pour en
arriver là à mon âge
mais a travaillé pendant plus de 20 ans
dans la même usine avant d'être
licenciée sans préavis à 50 ans le seul
plaisir qu'elle peut souffrir ce sont
ces quelques heures passées une fois par
mois dans un karaoké du xiiie
arrondissement
[Musique]
bref aujourd'hui c'est quoi
maintenant
trouver un bon mari bien vivre trouver
un boulot avoir une vie stable
si je me marie en france j'aurais des
papiers et un travail alors je n'aurai
pas peur d'être arrêté je serai
tranquille
jeannie
mais y aller c'est un fils de 25 ans
dans le doubs bay il vient de se marier
et attend un heureux événement pour
bientôt un petit fils que mais il ne
pourra pas serrer dans ses bras avant
longtemps depuis qu'elles sont
la chine pour elle c'est fini
[Musique]